so in a year that's already seen
comedies like 21 Jump Street and Ted the
watch has some serious shoes to fill in
the watch ben stiller decides to form
this neighborhood watch group because a
friend of his was murdered so these four
guys get together and they decide to
roam the neighborhood looking for
trouble day and night trying to figure
out who killed this guy and they run
into an alien invasion that's right a
neighborhood watch team and aliens now
we have our movie now I like all these
guys alright Jonah Hill Ben Stiller
Vince Vaughn I really like those
comedians I've liked a lot of their
films in the past the gentleman from
flight of the conchords Richard some IO
Waddy or something like that I can't
pronounce his name but they all have
nice rapport with one another but the
thing about this movie is that although
the plot is kind of interesting kind of
funny there could be a lot of humor
there el alien invasion
geeky neighborhood watch squad you know
there really is nothing holding this
movie together the script isn't run that
funny and I feel bad saying that since
one of the co writers is Seth Rogen
who's one of my favorite comedians the
movie is just very all over the place
scattered here and there lots and lots
and lots of cliches and really bad
dialogue and this movie is a really
prime example the fact that no matter
how funny you are as a comedian or as an
actor or good you are at improv like say
Vince Vaughn or Jonah Hill you really
need a good script to propel you you
know to give you some inspiration and
this movie just doesn't really have that
and actually my favorite part of this
movie were like the more sci-fi action
sequences involving the aliens and some
of the action scenes that were involved
with that those were actually some of my
more favorite parts of this movie the
scenes where the guys are just sitting
around talking that should have been
comedic gold that should have been
excellent that should have been some of
the best can make dialogue of the year
judging by the cast we have here alone
but this movie just doesn't really have
that it's just not really that funny
actually I'm if you saw the trailer for
this movie and you thought and that's
basically how I felt leaving the movie
and most of the people I talked to had a
similar feel where they just thought it
was okay it really it's it's okay it's
the kind of movie that when you're
watching it you know you're just it's
there you know you're watching it it's I
guess it's entertaining possibly it's
just that when you leave it's like
you'll never really think about this
movie again in fact it's been a day
since I've seen it now and I've barely
thought about it at all it's just a very
forgetful comedy especially in a year
we've had like American Reunion in 21
Jump Street and Ted this movie just
isn't up to par with some of the
comedies that have already come
this year I do like some of the stars in
this movie I think that they worked off
each other really well I do like some of
the action set-pieces in the film and
the movie has a nice look to it it was
directed it was fine you know it looked
fine it's okay it's just that the script
was there's nothing really there for
these actors to work with but really my
biggest problem with this movie was a
direction that it took someone towards
the latter half of the film absolutely
no sense it's dumb
it was dumb there really was no reason
for it especially considering what
happened after that happened which made
the fact that that happened meaningless
it was dumb it was stupid the watch is a
movie where its title is perfect for it
because you really you just kind of
watch it you just watched the watch and
then you're done with it that was a dumb
pun what I'm gonna give the watch a C+
if you decide to see it you might enjoy
it yeah I would just rent it when it
comes out to be honest it's not really
worth the time or the money I would say
go see Batman again I mean the movie
really needs the money doesn't it
support your indie filmmakers so I'd
like to know what's a movie you guys
went into and you're like man with a
cast like this this has got to be
special this has to be good and then it
just kind of deflated and as always guys
if you like this review you can
subscribe to my channel and get steppen
eyes